In this regard,
I want to announce
that we will promote a new reform
of the development regulations
of the organic law on foreigners
to simplify procedures and improve protection
of migrants' rights.
Our goal is to complete this modification
of the regulations before the first half of the year
of this coming year,
2 024 that is about to begin.
This reform aims to
the transposition of the directives
I have mentioned to you before,
as well as reduce the multiple permit figures
which are now in force
and also the objective of simplifying
documentation and formalities
and strengthen protection
of migrants against exploitation